This attack that took place in the
fairly small city in Christchurch,
New Zealand, was one with
massive ramifications.
This is part of an increasingly global
phenomenon of white nationalist,
white supremacist violence.
My name is Kanishk Tharoor.
I am an author and a broadcaster
and I write quite a bit about
multiculturalism and globalization.
The attacker in Christchurch inscribed
on his gun the name of
an Italian militant who shot six
African men in Italy in 2017.
He also inscribed the name
of the Québécois man
who went into a mosque in 2017
and killed six worshippers there.
He was consciously enacting his part
in what he sees as a global struggle.
The Christchurch killer simply described
Muslims and immigrants as "invaders."
And so we get this immediate
language of invasion, of opposition,
of clash and war almost.
You see echoes of that in the way the
man who committed the attack
on the Tree of Life Synagogue in Pittsburgh
would refer to immigrants as "invaders."
He was particularly angry with the HIAS activists
in the synagogue
because they were helping settle refugees.
If you look at attacks on places of worship
just in the United States
in the last seven years,
you've had a white nationalist attack
on a Sikh Gurdwara in Wisconsin,
on a predominantly Black
church in Charleston,
on a synagogue in Pennsylvania.
This is an ideology and a tendency in
American life and American society
that goes beyond just hatred of Muslims.
These white nationalist ideas are available freely
in the sort of far-right and right-wing media landscape.
Ideas like the "white genocide"
or the "great replacement theory" come out of
the mouths of mainstream politicians.
People like Steve King,
the congressman in Iowa who said
famously that
"We cannot restore our civilization with other people's babies."
A chilling statement for any American politician to make.
And in terms of what it suggests about
the way he understands
culture and citizenship and belonging.
But likewise, you have a Fox News anchor
like Laura Ingraham saying that
"The America we know and love no longer exists ... "
"The America that we know and
love doesn't exist anymore.
Massive demographic changes have been
foisted upon the American people
and they are changes that none of us ever
voted for. And most of us don't like."
Now, look at that language:
"Massive demographic changes have been
foisted upon the American people."
Not only is that untrue,
but what it's suggesting to its audience
very deliberately is that
what they imagine as great demographic
change is being done to them.
And this borrows completely from the way
white nationalists also frame the issue
of immigration, the issue of
demographic change in their societies.
It's not surprising that
somebody like David Duke,
the former head of the KKK,
was quick to congratulate Laura Ingraham
and say that what he had heard her say
on the TV was "the most important and
truthful monologue
he'd heard in American media."
The president of the United States
happily uses the same rhetoric.
Just a matter of hours after
the Christchurch attack,
he was sitting in the Oval Office,
happily decrying what he called the "invasion"
of his country by Latin American immigrants.
"People hate the word 'invasion,'
but that's what it is.
It's an invasion of drugs and criminals.
And in some cases, you have killers coming
in and murderers coming in
and we're not going to allow that to happen."
It's galling to see that language also
come out
of the most powerful office in the world.
I think a lot of white nationalist
terrorists see in Trump a figure
who vindicates for them
their rise on the world stage.
Until we as people who live in ostensibly
liberal societies can stress
that it's important to find solidarity
in our differences,
bigotry of this kind is
only going to get stronger.